I mean I think are you happy is is a
good and you know is a good question to
ask I think it's a hard question for
people to answer truthfully because I
think I don't want to say people are
fooling themselves into thinking they're
happy but I don't know and and you know
I I can't take credit for you know being
such an introspective person about my
life that I've that I've you know I'm
not fooling myself that I'm happy all
right I just get the feeling that there
are a lot of people especially in the
United States aren't that happy with
what they're doing and I don't know I
think taking a good because maybe taking
a good look at yourself and really kind
of digging down and like is this what I
want to be doing with my life would I be
happier doing something else would I be
happier with someone else would I be
happier with a family would I be happier
without a family would I be happier if I
took a lower paying job you know that
means I don't have a fancy car and I
don't get to go out to nice restaurants
but if I took a lower paying job you
know doing something i really love would
that make me happier and you know it
might